bonjour faire une pharmacie jeu merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france pour parler de
cette visite marine le pen cette visite
de marine le pen a été très commentée
dans les médias en france comment cette
rencontre et elle rapporté dans les
médias en anglais
il a écouté ce qui est intéressant
qu'une chose c'est que elle elle a passé
deux jours à budapest
est là il a rencontré viktor orban
officiellement donc le haut à la fin de
la fin pour le déjeuner du deuxième jour
et l'après midi le rendez vous a duré
longtemps
avant la rencontre la presse hongroise
est assez discrète qui semblait que tout
le monde attendait le set cette
discussion publique c'est cette
conférence de presse par dont
il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de spéculations
en réalité il ya assez clair en gris que
pour or ban il est important d'avoir de
nouveaux alliés européens depuis qu'il
est sorti du ppe
le fait que le front national est
longtemps été un parti avec lequel le
discours n'était pas possible pas prévu
cercle tant que le fidèles étaient au
ppe il y avait une un cordon sanitaire
comme on dit en france
ça ça complètement sauté mais ça n'a pas
spécialement choqué ang lee qui est un
pays où il ya eu une très grande
recomposition du champ politique
donc ce genre de chose en soi n'est pas
choquant et il n'y a pas de tabou sur le
front national en hongrie donc si vous
voulez une relative attentisme de la
presse hongroise jusqu'à l'arrivée de
madame le pen ensuite si vous voulez
lors de la conférence de presse il n'y a
rien eu de particulièrement n'y a pas de
grande annonce il ya rien eu de
particulier
on sait qu'il ya une volonté de
coopération
ça a été répétée est confirmé mais il
n'y a pas vraiment eu de nouveauté ni de
grande annonce donc havrais dir du point
de vue de la presse hongroise il ya
presque une déception puisque on attend
évidemment depuis plusieurs mois
l'annoncé de la création d'un groupe au
parlement européen qui rassemblerait
entre autres le fidesz de viktor orban
et le rassemblement national de marine
le pen jusqu'à victoria on va n'était
auparavant dans le groupe du parti
français les républicains en europe
d'ailleurs en ce qui concerne l'écriture
visite est ce que des candidats les
républicains sont prévues ou pas
c'est une bonne question pas que je
sache je crois que
il y à il ya des gens chez les
républicains
qui sont toujours bien vus par la
hongrie puisqu'il ya certaines personnes
pour ne pas citer nadine morano ou
monsieur bellamy qui ont qui ont souvent
voté en faveur de la hongrie ou en tout
cas pas contre la hongrie lors des votes
du parlement européen c'est pas le cas
de tout le parti la plupart des des
eurodéputés et l'air en général suivent
la ligne progressiste et la ligne
comment dire
plutôt du du ppe 1
et donc ont souvent eu à voter contre
contre la hongrie
c'est quelque chose qui a été
qui a été pris en compte par la hongrie
maintenant si chez les verts il ya enfin
candidat qui est déclarée valide et etc
je pense que s'ils font la demande en
comprennent victor van ce n'est pas
quelque chose à exclure viktor orban a à
a répondu d'ailleurs aux questions des
journalistes l'interrogeant lors d'un
conférence de presse sur
pourquoi il reçoit et zemmour et madame
le pen
lui il a il a botté en touche de manière
diplomatique évidemment puisqu'ils ne
font pas sans s'ingérer dans la
politique française
madame la présidente on l'a entendu vous
entendu oui alors attention attention
parce que ça c'est c'est ça peut être
mal compris peut-être que il en joue
mais en gris il est convenu d'appeler
ainsi et président de parti ce n'est pas
du tout
un sous-entendu
comme on pourrait le comprendre en
france il a il a néanmoins reconnu que
marine le pen pouvait avoir une stature
de chef d'état
oui je crois que il là ils ont mis les
petits plats dans les grands pour
accueillir marine le pen il faut voir
que du côté des points de vue
protocolaire il ya vraiment eu des
efforts qui ont été faits pour donner à
marine le pen à cette visite une stature
qui en effet est pas loin de ce que
pourrait recevoir un chef d'état de
gouvernement oui je pense que c'est
aussi une opération séduction de la part
de 8h obame qui comme on disait a besoin
d'alliés au niveau européen alors on
parle de chefs d'état on attend aussi à
la visite des manuels mâcon puisqu'il
fait le tour des pays européens avant ça
avant la prise de sa présidence en
janvier prochain il fera l'impasse sur
sur la rentrée vous pensez
je ne pense pas il faut se rappeler que
emmanuel macron a reçu
viktor orban a paris
il ya quelques mois je pense que pensiez
moment il veut faire le tour des 27 il
faudra passer par la case hongrie ce
sera très intéressant à suivre puisque
en avril 2022 lieu les élections en
france mais aussi en gris
donc ça va être quelque chose de délicat
à caser dans l'agenda des deux hommes
forts de l'europe à suivre pour
l'instant il n'y a rien d'annoncé à
l'est la hongrie qui reste et qui fait
figure de l'un des rares pays de l'union
européenne qui défend ses valeurs et sa
souveraineté face à la toute-puissance
de la commission européenne souvent
incompris d'ailleurs à l'ouest est ce
que la défense de ces valeurs est une
priorité pour les au moins est ce qu'ils
se rendent compte de la vision qu'on
nous
les états ouest européen
la réponse est dans la question il ya
une très grande incompréhension entre
l'est et l'ouest
c'est à dire qu' il ya des choses qui
pour la majorité des hongrois sont
complètement incompréhensible lorsque
vous parlez de de certains certaine
vision du monde ou de l'homme en fait
liés au lobby lgbt il ya des choses qui
sont complètement insaisissable pour les
hongrois et
d'expérience évidemment je le vois bien
je suis en première ligne il y a à
l'ouest aussi une incompréhension
profonde et et voir une pâture de dupes
et
avoir plus qu'une caricature c'est que
c'est oui bien sûr c'est que quand on
lit que victor ban est un ultra
nationalistes ou que la régie la hongrie
est un régime autoritaire enfin c'est du
délire total et je crois que ça n'aide
pas du tout à faire avancer le débat
mais peut-être que certains ne
souhaitent pas de débat
merci beaucoup feirense almaci d'avoir
répondu ce matin à nos questions sur
arte france